hey potus is olivia rodriguez still here
we vaccinated 160 million americans are
you getting this all down don't worry
queen all right here
what in the actual
speaking of people losing their absolute
ever-loving mind
the white house has now decided that it
is necessary to team up with tick-tock
stars tik-tok stars to encourage people
to get vaccinated because if there is
one group of people that i would say
rural trump voters love it is tick tock
stars love them they are so into it now
the white house is spending real money
on this according to the new york times
just a couple of days ago ellie zeiler
17 a tick tock creator with over 10
million followers received an email in
june from village marketing in
influencer marketing agency it said it
was reaching out on behalf of another
party the white house would miss zeiler
a high school senior who usually posts
short fashion and lifestyle videos be
willing the agency wanted to participate
in a white house backed campaign
encouraging her audience to get
vaccinated against the coronavirus miss
zeiler quickly agreed joining a broad
personality driven campaign to confront
an increasingly urgent challenge in the
fight against the pandemic vaccinating
the youthful masses who have the lowest
inoculation rates of any eligible age
group in the united states
the white house has enlisted an eclectic
army of more than 50 twitch streamers
youtubers tick-tockers and the
18-year-old pop star olivia rodrigo all
of them with enormous online audiences
by the way i would love to see a study
to see
how much it costs like for each
vaccination how much is this actually
costing
that that i think would be uh
fascinating to see okay here is uh we we
now have the greatest example of vaccine
messaging i have ever seen courtesy of
the white house and it is
just spectacular i mean it is
unparalleled and it's in its wonder
i don't know who this youtube influencer
is this tic toc influencer
frankly i don't really want to know i
guess this is a person i'm looking it up
right now it's a person named benny
drama which sounds just spectacular
according to the uk daily mail benito
skinner a comedian whose tic-tock handle
is benny drama he boasts over 845 000
followers posted a video on monday which
featured a day in my life as a white
house intern
the video is also posted to instagram
and twitter as well
and um
here is um
here is a little bit of the video that
your tax dollars get to pay for
hi my name is cooper and this is a day
in my life as a white house intern
[Music]
we did a joke
hey everyone vogue this is actually the
entrance to the west wing this is so fun
and it's really prestigious hey potus is
olivia rodriguez still here no
we've come a long way in our fight
against this virus we've vaccinated 160
million americans are you getting this
all down don't worry queen all right
here
uh e
and then and then what
what in the actual
what was that
what no
so yeah
when we're talking about the groups
least likely to be vaccinated in america
by pole statistics it is people who
identify as republicans
and black and hispanic americans
i'm just wondering
is this benny drama character like super
popular among either rural trump voters
and tucker carlson watchers or
black americans living in the inner city
like who's the who's the core audience
for benny drama
and
his her sure i i don't want to assume
anybody's gender here i i have no idea i
guess i guess he identifies as he so i'm
i can that's exciting actually frankly
i'm excited because i knew that was a
man so now that i get to say that that's
a man that's exciting that's the society
we now live in so i can say he without
being banned on twitter or facebook
that's exciting so he apparently uh
we're donning his skirt and also long
white nails and making ridiculous jokes
with jen saki
that is going to uh that's going to
convince millions of people to get
vaccinated as well also you will notice
that neither this person nor gensake are
wearing masks
yes well in close proximity with one
another apparently the video was filmed
on july 12th the white house official
july 20th rather a white house official
told daily mail before the mass
requirements were reinstated
just spectacular
that that's this is great again i'm so
glad i'm sorry our country's so stupid
like we are we are we're beyond the
point of of
return i think i think we may be done i
think it's time whoever last person now
turn out the lights like don't don't run
up the electricity bills because
we're toast like we got a real problem
what should convince you to get a
vaccine is a pretty simple fact which is
that for virtually everybody in the
united states the chances of getting
covered and then dying from covet are
significantly higher than the chances of
getting a serious adverse effect and
dying from a vaccine
that's true for pretty much everyone as
far as the data are concerned
that seems like that should be a better
argument than here is
a strange person from tiktok
posing with gensake and making bizarre
jokes about vaccines while wearing fake
nails and wearing a skirt
and doing things that no one understands
yeah but
there's a point in which words simply
fail and i think we we may have reached
that point i know what you're thinking
it's time to binge some more ben shapiro
videos well you are right you should but
first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video